I'm a believer bro yeah one time my mom
said you need to get a job I said I
already have a job I'm just like getting
paid yet I want to plan for the next 20
years of my life like what am I going to
be doing when I'm 50 there's a spark in
every single person that's going to
change the world they have this spark in
them hello believe nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from rapper and
successful entrepreneur will.i.am and my
take on his top ten rules of success and
as always as you're listening if
something really resonates with you
there's a message that really holds true
to you please leave it down the comments
below and put it in quotes so that other
people can be inspired and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy
I'm a believer broke I like I see things
and I wanted to make them real no matter
how how hard it takes no matter what
obstacles no matter how many
embarrassing meetings I have to imagine
it's happening when I leave
does it matter I'm a doer and a freaking
make it happen er yeah one time my mom
said you need to get a job I said I
already have a job I'm just not getting
paid yet actually I have a career but
that's a huge pinch like real stuff then
I'm working on my dream that's my job if
I'm going to pay attention to my
nightmare I should be able to work on my
dream what some some one of them is
going to take my energy I would rather
give my energy to my dream that my
nightmare creativity feels like the
world slows down and fast forwards at
the same time it's like your stash for
eating in slow motion the only thing
that matters is what you're creating and
then you go to sleep and you wake up
awake back but it all felt like 24 hours
but the stuff that you're able to do
with my bong
and for those sound like puzzle like
what are you talking about I don't get
it
stop progression are creative creative
folks we know fat ones are mom time just
seems to just fly by time doesn't exist
when you're creating oh my gosh present
so what time is it 4:00 o'clock no it's
5 o'clock in the morning well some just
out well the Sun is out but the Sun went
down and came back up again oh man I you
crazy I'm eating all day but you weren't
hungry you get hit with nah you're
lethargic and you're freaking charged
and lips are all trapped and dry your
breath smells because you even talking
he's been thinking and the little
talking you were doing was to figure out
these problems that is the most
enjoyable experience ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
- oh that sums you up all that would
become like a little beacon will not an
egotistical either just the will and not
the thing you're right before you die
the will to have will determination to
have strength courage will Apple and I
we always used to think big but we
didn't think as big as we made it our
whole thing was how do we stay traveling
when you're in a ghetto or a province
you yearn to travel to see like one day
I want to go to London one day I want to
go to Cambodia see the ruins
well what's what do I have to do to be
able to travel or what my craft now is
writing songs and performing so you mash
your craft to do something that you
wanted to do like how do I move my mom
out the projects how do I move my entire
family out the projects my uncles
cousins and a few nieces
so you master your craft to be able to
do that I'm just a tech enthusiast I
want to plan for the next 20 years of my
life like what am I going to be doing
when I'm 50 and I remember when I was 17
I dreamt of doing music and now those
dreams came true and I indulged in music
I surrounded myself with beats and
people that wrote rhyme went to poetry
lounges I made an effort to be doing
what I'm doing now I discipline myself
and sacrificed a whole bunch of stuff to
keep me on track and now I'm in my 30s
what am I going to when I'm 50 I hope
I'm making I want to be creating tools
don't gadgets so I'm starting now maybe
some it's going to be wet just like the
first songs I wrote were whack I wrote
the wack song yesterday but that doesn't
mean that you stop that means you just
keep going keep going and proving and
proving sharpen up your tool you know
keeping your mind fast keeping your eyes
open your mind open to to you know to be
in the creative community and in
tomorrow the creative communities is
gadgets technology software then I want
to be a part of it can you achieve this
kind of thing without the driving force
of a mother or a father somebody who's
with you to be able to provide a chance
to do it what depends on the people
around you sometimes your friends good
friends replace that of course you can
hear I mean I can't speak for those
people I'm speaking for me being raised
by a single mom and uncles and friends
that pitched in and
but yes just there's always ways out of
it sometimes takes difficult decisions
to do things to leap she's got a leap
especially if you know it's better than
just sitting there and bickering and
fighting and right and waiting for
people to make it happen for you if
someone confronts me with an idea for a
new business the thing that that I look
for to see if they're going to succeed
first off on a personal level is how
they vibrate you know are they excited
about it and if they have more facts
than dreams because anybody could have a
whole bunch of dreams and no concrete
you know way to turn that dream into
reality like facts because you could be
hypnotized and dizzy by your own
dreaming so I look for that but the
tenacity that that energy there's a
there's a spark in every single person
that's going to change the world they
have this spark in them and they are
able to make you believe you know they
don't necessarily have to be the most
energetic person just magnetic and how
they're delivering you that contact
they're converters and then
business-wise if they don't have the
business skills they're open minded and
they're converters to bring along the
best business folk like what what gives
me wasn't the best business person but
his brother was so but he was able to he
was able to you know dream and convert
right not convert in a way that's you
know forceful but it inspired it's a
better word for able to dream and
inspire to and become magnetic to bring
all the right components to the table
for that thing to grow successfully that
is that's hard to do though and those
people
don't come around very often and it's
the reason why those same people have
their hands and a whole bunch of
disruptive businesses right
it took a LAN mus to do all three of
those because not many people have the
ability to do that there's these bars
that other people that are in your field
have accomplished and that becomes the
measurement of what people define as
success when in a Grammy that's it
that's the summit so everyone tries to
win a Grammy some people don't even dare
to think they don't want to not succeed
and then they find themselves one of the
Grammy
okay after you want it then what you
know then what see you so for me it's
creating new things coming up with
concepts like I want to send kids to
college so how do I send kids to college
via my art right so if I just by me
being creative I send kids to school
that's a bar you've now lifted you know
twenty thousand pounds so once you did
that okay what can I do you know I want
to rescue families from losing their
home and via me being creative so that's
now a new bar
you
yeah
No
Hey
[Music]
right
holy track of the things that our
previous service say Lucy I suppose of
the trips of the KKK but if you only
unlovely always see these please
discriminate as you discriminate only to
the race late I would hate to get on
again all right here's what you did this
week to the street take a chocolate lava
just yes
the last one right now yah
with all the sprinklers happening we're
on to put their weed
check one another and a few black and
white all lives matter
right now right now we need you to step
aside step aside yo-yo we are very good
at the other day let's trace our
countries are straight for the family
though there's a foot halfway because of
ignorance and hatred
where's the Liao's and supporters right
now
I'm just really really really really
hurt by the things that are happening in
the world right now so take it to say a
prayer
and often police officers out there
let's say pray and to the wicked would
they don't show that if it's upon us
very very alive thank you for seeing
these songs from Bobby I just really was
driving on the street you saw you as a
house and I just wanted it is happening
on the quantum enter so
laughs thank you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Michael rezku
asked me to is there someone you like me
to profile in the next top 10 check out
the link in the description and go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what was your favorite message from this
video what did you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
a really curious find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to delete yellow
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and taking that
picture on Instagram I really really
really appreciate man and I hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
way before it was cool and put myself in
jeopardy to to the youth to look at me
like an adult like oh that's that
politically my I put my career at risk
the way I stepped out and you know was
on a bill bar and and a Larry King and
whatnot that's when you when you're a
group like the black-eyed peas and you
know you got like 15 year-olds to my 40
year olds 40 year old you food he was
idle and you're like four-year-olds
think it's cool but a 15 year old be
like Jane I do is like oh yeah so you
know I put up my career at risk doing
that and because I believe in it I'm a
believer and I believe in putting teams
together whether it's for songs whether
it's for political campaigns and the
likes of Obama campaign and Hillary
campaign and Intel and beeps and now
Apple they value you know doc connectors
and problem-solvers people that trying
to solve riddles so I wanted to believe
in my ability to create my own team so I
went out and invested in myself I have a
song called it was all the drink me yes
sorry god it was all a dream I used to
read Word Up Magazine salt and pepper a
Heavy D and limousine it was all a dream
I used to read Word Up Magazine some
pepper and HEVC up in the hummus me
hanging pictures of my was yeah every
facetted era patek and your pictures on
my wall have we started a rap attack
with the magic multi-ball for me it was
all the dream i used to search google
I used to buy an iPhone and now I want
to make my own why not yes when I dream
that big